Uh,
and I have not only a the pleasure,
but the privilege of introducing a,
and we're going to be having a talk today.
So before we get started,
I want to read a quick bio.
So Shanti sacred teaches creative writing at the California College of Arts and
is a member of the San Francisco riders grotto.
Her work has appeared in the New York Times best new American voices and
Huffington post and online at [inaudible] and mother magazine.
Her first novel,
the prayer room was published by Macadam cage.
She is a California native who lives in Berkeley with her husband and two
children.
And today we're going to be talking about her book lucky boy,
which follows two stories that have solely Castro Valdez and undocumented
undocumented Mexican woman and that of Rishi and Kavio ready and Indian American
couple who live in Berkeley,
California as well.
Please welcome me in joining.
Shanti,
go ahead and start off by thanking t for being here.
I had the pleasure of meeting with her a couple of weeks ago,
so I'm particularly excited for today.
Um,
but I'd love to just start with maybe reading a couple excerpts from the book.
Sure.
Yeah.
So I'm going to read two excerpts from the two sides of the story.
So one side is,
one of my main characters is an undocumented young Mexican woman who crosses
into California from Mexico.
She's from Wahaca,
Mexico and she ends up in Berkeley,
California not far from here.
So solely,
um,
I don't think you need to know much else about her.
She's uh,
she's crossing the border,
just getting close to it in this scene that I'm about to read right now.
And she's met a man named Chicco on her way.
She had sort of a romance on her journey.
Um,
so that's all you need to know.
And here we go.
It had been five days since solely had last seen Checo and thoughts of him and
what might have happened to him.
Jangled inside her like shards of 10 solely and two other women's sat on the bed
of a yellow onion truck with crate stat tie to shield them every now and then a
thin whistle of air and made it through the slats of the truck and passed the
crates and for those swift seconds,
she since the suite and Uranus of the end,
what the air,
the morning light,
the company of calm women among who she could at last close.
Her eyes solely felt that she would hold together cohered by a single strip of
hope just long enough to arrive at Sylvia's door.
They stopped twice that day to Piss on the side of the road and stretch their
legs,
so at least slept for how long she did not know.
She did not dream of what had happened to her.
She did not dream of Chico or if the British men who came later,
the case between her legs was numb,
but her thighs were sticky and began to blister the day's heat.
When she awoke,
the air was still a woman named Luce,
squinted at her across the mound of onions.
Where are you going?
She asked Berkeley solely answered.
Where's that close to San Francisco.
You know someone there?
Yes.
My cousin.
Your cousin have money?
I think so.
I think she has money lose.
Shook her head like she did not see good things for solely a few hours after
dark,
the driver stopped the truck and stuck his head out his window.
Get flat.
He called.
What's he talking about?
Solely asked lose,
rolled herself into a ball.
The truck slowed to a halt.
The engine stopped.
Get down,
she hissed and pulled sleeping fatty mouth from the bench to the floor
or we hear [inaudible] quiet,
make yourself small through the crates and the slats solely saw the flicker of a
dark green uniform.
The flicker spoken English.
He spoke in English,
we're here so they whispered.
Shut up.
Loose was kneeling beside her and she took us all these hand in hers.
She slipped her fingers along solely his knuckles like they were rosary beads
and solely prayed silently thinking of her own lost rosary though his words were
muffled by onions.
She knew the uniform demand was questioning their driver.
Shuffling paper,
more questions and before she could move a stick shot through the slats,
she gasped.
It grazed her skull again and again.
It rammed through the slats,
a guards iron wand,
trawling for migrant flesh hoping to hit something live enough to cry out and
prove the truck carried more than onions.
She held her hands to her head and prayed.
She knew she was shaking,
but luckily for her fear made no sound.
Moments later she heard footsteps crunch away and vanish.
The engine started up again and they rolled forward.
Loose,
released,
released a tremulous breath.
Lucky she said,
a lazy one.
She looked up at solely grinned and pushed her tongue through the gap in her
teeth
were here in the North America.
Amea.
That's what they call it.
Here we are in California.
Now solely looked up to the sky.
Same blue as the Mexicans guy.
She looked through the truck's slats.
This was California,
the United States of America.
She had arrived and here's what she discovered.
This place,
this America,
this new place.
This streets of gold place looked a hell of a lot like the old place.
America streaked by her stripped and tender with heat.
She watched it all.
Rush pass through the slats of the old truck,
the tin roofs sees of broken glass glinting and breathless like a fever dream
America was it Dustin?
Her hair,
the wind in her throat,
the sun that shouted against her eyelids between the slats of this truck,
America was nothing but a high tech,
high speed dream of trees and houses and fences,
a sliver of interrupted light.
The old folks back home,
those who'd been here in back told solely she would do well here,
that she had the spirit,
they told her to keep her head down and work hard and for God's sake keep her
mouth shut.
Okay.
Yeah.
So that's solely,
um,
the other side of my story is a couple of named caveat and Rishi ready.
They live in Berkeley and coffee is a chef at a sorority,
which is its own story.
But um,
Rishi is a worker at a Silicon Valley company.
He does stuff with air quality in buildings.
So he works for this gigantic Silicon Valley company that I made up.
It's called the webbies and it's a,
it's one of these,
it's a company that just,
it's like a gigantic Amazon for children's and babies suppliers combined with
some social networking stuff.
Um,
so this little bit is going to be a little bit from copyists point of view,
but then we're going to transition and to me,
she's point of view and here we go.
Despite the clarity of her desire,
Kavya had no real idea of what sort of mother she'd be,
the parents around her.
It seemed to take great pride in their work,
like artisans of a dying craft,
jogging through parks and waiting and Bart Stations Kavya had come across
American mother's speaking French to their American children,
fathers explaining the physics of underground transport to their preschoolers
property tax law to their eight year olds at the farmer's market the week before
a little girl had fallen and scraped her knee as she stood,
sobbing,
inconsolable.
Her mother knelt down beside her here,
sweetie,
have some Kale.
And she's,
uh,
the little girl had taken it,
chewed on the tough primordial leaf and stopped crying.
The stakes were high in Berkeley.
The toddlers were eating there.
Cruciferous Greens.
There were things she couldn't know about being a parent without being one.
This she sends from the way men and women with children in tow seem to have
little to say to her.
Parenthood was a members only organization closed to freelancers and temps.
Outsiders could visit for lunch,
but they tended to leave quickly overwhelmed by the demands of belonging,
but Kavio didn't want to leave.
Kavya wanted to in
for Rishi,
the brilliant bonus of this new world,
this procreative world was a sudden abundance of sex.
They were doing it every day,
sometimes twice like they'd done in the early days.
They had sex for lunch and eat burritos in the car.
They had sex in the living room and topple the throw pillows from the sofa.
They had sex in a restaurant once in the bathroom and once in a parking lot,
but after two months,
then three,
these trysts began to feel inappropriate like their control was slipping.
He began to wonder what it was about.
All the spontaneity he supposed Kavio was trying to keep things fun.
Maybe even for his sake to combat the impatience that lurked in the shadows for
three months.
Kavya refused to look at her calendar or take her temperature or do any of the
things a woman did to track their fertility.
It shouldn't matter.
She said it should just happen,
but then it didn't just happen.
After three months of trying and failing that sex could no longer be casual.
She began taking her temperature,
tracking her oblation Rishi had been on board with us.
He would think of it as a project.
He decided project managing was what he did and driving his management approach
was the Weebly's principle,
the silicon valley principle that nothing was impossible.
Impossibility was not an absolute,
but it's shiftable as a heavy boulder trial and error and a little cognitive
daring.
We're all it took to make the impossible possible.
It had worked for PC's,
the Internet,
smartphones,
it would work for his baby sex.
Whenever it became sex on a schedule,
Kavya felt a sense of purpose,
satisfaction,
even she was taking charge.
Kavya began demanding sex is Rishi hurried from the house to catch the wave us
she wants actually drove out to the [inaudible] campus and showed up at his
office store.
I'm obviating right now.
She said like now rush.
She had found them a nap room disobeying the strict single occupant limit.
They did merge,
flushed and rumbled and full you view of his coworkers gathered at the espresso
machine often from across the bay.
She texted him in all caps,
mid meeting,
mid presentation,
mid epiphany to say,
come home.
I need you now.
What once would have thrilled Rishi stirred in him a sense of anxiety,
futility in gratitude.
He felt less like a man and more like an indentured servant keeping up his end
of a shady bargain.
And every time,
every month they tried to get pregnant.
Rishi watched Kavya grow more brittle.
He thought of himself as a rational person,
good at compartmentalizing,
good at avoiding flights of fancy,
but trying to have a baby to fight as powers of reason and strategy and desire.
He bought into the idea that hard work bred success,
but Rishi and Kavya were working hard.
They were working a naturally hard at this most natural of tasks.
Six months passed and still nine months and Kavya had found herself at Preethy
these wedding and now 10 the gravel in her throat had grown to a stone.
Every time she saw a baby or a woman with a luscious globe of a belly,
the stone grew harder and larger,
but Kavio knew this much.
She was a woman.
She was an Indian woman.
Surely a country with 1 billion people had produced some capable wounds.
She was going to have a baby.
She and Rishi just needed to get away from the theater of failure that had
become their bedroom.
They needed to escape the chili corners of their bungalow and have the sort of
relaxed intercourse from which babies seem to spring or ears buzzed with
certainty and farther inside her ovaries winced.
She texted Rishi Napa valley this weekend,
SPA BNB on booking
the exclamation mark.
So hopeful she began to delete it,
then decided to let it be
[inaudible].
Thank you so much.
I,
I don't know about those of you that heard it,
but I went through the full range of emotions from like the powerful,
beautiful descriptive language in the first one to uh,
I dunno,
the second uh,
segment seemed a little familiar.
I think you did a great job at capturing all world tech in the bay area in
general.
Uh,
so before we go into lucky boy,
I'd love to just hear about your beginning as an author.
Like what's that journey like that you always know you wanted to right.
Um,
I did not always know that I want to try it.
I knew that I loved books and I think my brothers,
I have these two older brothers who are 10 years and 11 years older than me.
I think they knew before I did,
we used to play fresh air,
like wasted.
Like pretend we were on fresh air and together,
like my brother would be Terry Gross and I would be me talking about a book.
And,
um,
so I think they had some sense that this was what I loved,
but I'd spent a lot of my school years thinking I was going to be like an
English literature professor until I realized how theoretical that field is.
And what I loved was the books and the language and talking about that.
So it was really only when I was about 22 that I had started writing creatively
and took really just the first pages of like my first attempt to creative
writing and sent those into an MFA program and got in,
got into one and went to that one and
took it from there.
I was just to sort of see if this was something that I could do.
And so it was a slow process,
but the love of books was always there.
I love that.
That's wonderful.
Yeah,
I feel like we're all,
at least for me,
I'm still trying to figure out like what is,
what is a niche?
Like what is the thing to do?
And I love hearing from authors their journey because it ranges from always
knowing that you wanted to write just one day.
Realizing that it's your passion.
Um,
and in terms of genre,
did you ever think about what you wanted to write,
whether it was fiction or nonfiction,
particular topics?
I
had always wanted to write fiction.
I think poetry is kind of scary.
I really admire poets,
but you really,
there's no safety net with,
with poetry,
you're really putting yourself out there.
Um,
nonfiction,
you know,
this was the closest I've ever come to nonfiction as a writer.
So this took a lot of research and um,
I now feel like more adept at nonfiction.
I feel like I can go in that direction,
but it took a sort of transitional book,
like lucky boy.
Yeah.
So it's wonderful because it is,
it is a fiction book and yet there are so many areas that when you and I
chatted,
you really wanted to explore it and make sure that you,
you know,
do it justice.
So do you mind telling us a little bit about your preparation and learning about
tech companies immigration,
the lender's experience?
Yeah.
So I was faced with this task of writing,
you know,
writing these worlds that I was not familiar with from Soliz world,
the silicon valley or worlds to fertility issues.
So I started very basic with some documentaries and oral histories.
Just getting a sense of,
you know,
what the undocumented experience might be like for people,
what it's like to cross the border,
why people feel they need to leave their homes and come to America.
Um,
it started pretty,
pretty sort of straight forward,
um,
in that way.
And then I started to just look for people who would talk to me.
So immigration lawyers,
immigration policy scholars,
um,
adoptive parents because Kavya and Rishi end up being foster parents to solely
his child.
Um,
yeah.
So in all of these realms,
you know,
people who'd undergone fertility treatments,
just anyone who would talk to me about their experience,
um,
I tried to get ahold of,
and people are pretty open when you're a novelist and not a journalist.
People are pretty willing to talk to you.
And with Silicon Valley,
I spent a day less like a few hours here with an less is here and just kind of
like went to lunch in the cafeteria,
walked around a little.
Um,
I've never worked in silicon valley,
so a lot of like,
I think I absorbed literally like 37 details and put them all in this book
during those few hours and then just living in California,
you know,
it's part of the zeitgeisty you absorb stuff as well.
That's wonderful.
Um,
I couldn't help but chuckle when you said the Wiebe us reminded me.
Yeah.
So I was like,
yeah,
I had all kinds of things like I had,
um,
we edited it out,
but I had the snack cupboard,
which was called [inaudible] because it's all free and I thought that was too
much,
but then we were outside and he called the dog a Dougal or do colors here.
Yeah,
I do.
Yeah.
This is why I appreciate it.
This knew that you had done your research and as I was reading through this and
I was like,
this is so accurate.
Yeah.
You did a great job of capturing it.
So,
speaking of tech,
obviously it's a predominant part of the book,
what role do you think tech has as an industry,
um,
in this topic and immigration?
What role does tech have in immigration?
Um,
you know,
I've been thinking about the h one B issues that have been coming up like in the
past few days.
And I see tech is the new,
it is the new industry in the world and especially in California and it needs
people.
It's,
uh,
it needs people who are capable and we're such a globalized society now that
immigration and Tech,
you know,
immigration feeds tech at this point.
And I feel like that's the way it should be.
Um,
and on the other side of it,
um,
being one of our biggest industries right now,
I feel like tech might have a role to play.
And I dunno in having a say in some of these issues and issues of immigration,
I'm not actually completely certain what I think of that.
You know,
I don't know if business should stay away from politics as business,
should stay away from,
um,
issues of immigration or not.
I'd sort of be interested to hear what people think being in this world.
Yeah.
We'll have an opportunity to get someone a questions,
maybe even some opinions from the group.
So,
speaking more about immigration,
uh,
there's a lot of themes in the book about immigration,
intersecting with motherhood or parenthood or family.
I feel like often in our nation we talk about immigration as an individual
topic.
So what opportunities do we have to be immigration from that more family or
motherhood perspective?
So one thing that I found out pretty early on is that of our 11 million
undocumented immigrants,
um,
within that statistic,
5 million children in the u s have at least one undocumented parent.
So we think of immigration.
You're right as a very individual pursuit.
You know,
America was built on these ideas of individualism versus collectivism and um,
and this idea of bootstraps and you know,
just being,
being your own person and forging your own way,
which is all very admirable.
But it's worth noting that these issues,
you know,
when we talk about undocumented immigrants,
we're not talking about the one immigrant who crosses the border on his own.
We're talking about the family that he might build in the u s his family back
home.
Uh,
we're talking about generations of ramifications for whatever we decide to do
with immigration.
Definitely.
Um,
and I liked that you were talking about that because we often think of an image
when we think of immigrant,
right?
And it's often the unlucky,
Or the unfortunate or,
uh,
having to deal with the same struggles.
But we have immigrants from all over the world and they come with different
experiences.
Um,
you wrote an op Ed in the New York Times called the,
uh,
the privileged immigrant.
Do you mind talking a little bit about that article and that,
how that correlates with what a lucky boy tells
us as well?
Yeah.
So the privileged immigrants that came out in November,
and it basically is a discussion of my own family's immigration experience,
which was that my parents came over in the 1960s as foreign medical graduates.
My Dad had graduated medical school at that point and the U s was trying to fill
it's hospitals with its,
um,
it's medicare network that had just been put in place.
So that article sort of looks at their experience of of yes being alienated,
yes,
struggling a lot,
but at least having,
you know,
having solid work and having a visa,
having like a solid legal way to be in the u s and that not only put them at
ease psychologically,
but it allowed them to put structures in place in their lives that have brought
them where they are today.
You know,
it allowed them to start savings accounts and start investing and buy property.
And um,
we see,
I,
I enjoy the fruits of that now and my kids enjoy the fruits of that.
So again,
we're going forward for generations.
And when you think about an undocumented immigrant,
you know,
there are,
there are structures in place where undocumented immigrants,
they can go to a bank and open a bank account,
but it's terrifying to walk into a bank.
You know,
we saw what just happened to the first Daca recipient who's who was deported.
Um,
it's,
it's scary to go in and give your official information to an institution when
you don't actually belong here with legal papers.
So it's really hard for undocumented immigrants.
I realized while researching this book to put those,
those building blocks in place for a stable future.
And how much of like your own personal experiences would you say influences look
cause in your first book that you wrote also has a lot of your personal
experiences as well as we'd love to see how much of that you incorporating
writing.
So my personal experiences,
you know,
in order to start to understand solely I had to understand her in my terms,
I had to relate to her as a person.
And so motherhood is in here a lot.
I have two kids.
Um,
there's some material right after the little boy is born in this book that comes
straight from what I had jotted down right after my little boy was born.
And then the ideas of immigration and particularly with Kavya and Rishi,
you know,
these ideas of ambition and what parents want for their children and what it's
like for a second generation Indian American or a second generation immigrant.
There is this unspoken sometimes spoken agreement between immigrant parents and
their children,
which basically says,
look,
I gave up everything I knew to come over here,
so you'd better do something with this.
Um,
and,
and so failure is not in many parents view an option,
you know,
so that that fed into coffee has experience in the story and it fed into rushees
experience and it also fed into the narrative around fertility and being able to
have a child.
That's wonderful.
Um,
so no,
that we,
when we were talking,
we were talking a lot about the things that you learned when you were doing
research.
Um,
and particularly when looking at the differences in immigrants,
there was,
uh,
the detention centers that you observe.
Then you learned a lot about that.
Can you tell us a little bit more about that experience?
What it was like to see what undocumented immigrants go through them?
Yes.
So I trained with a group called civic and isolation,
and they do a lot of work with undocumented immigrants.
They started out sort of providing legal representation because when you're in a
detention center,
you're not given a defense lawyer.
You're not given a lawyer.
It's not like being a criminal in the u s um,
so they were helping people find their families and also try to get some legal
aid for their situation.
Um,
and when I trained with them,
I visited the detention facility out in Richmond,
California,
and it was just,
you know,
I,
I didn't get to see where people were actually living.
Um,
and the Richmond facility is,
is,
is a somewhat reformed one.
Like people have a little more room to wander.
They can leave their rooms when they want,
they have a little more freedom.
But a lot of what I learned about detention centers came from writings in know
lawyers who have devoted their careers to researching different detention
centers.
And much of what I learned revolved around the fact that detention centers are
basically prisons.
They're often at,
within the prison facility itself.
Um,
but they're like prisons without facilities because it's not considered a
permanent,
a longterm solution for an immigrant.
Um,
so they don't give you like resources.
So if you're a parent in detention and you're separated from your American born
child,
like there's nothing there that allows you to reunite with your child,
you know?
So if a family court says,
okay,
we want you to do this and this and this to qualify for reunification,
like there's no way a detainee can do that because there's nothing in the center
for them.
Wow.
Yeah.
So the research behind it,
uh,
I mean I was so impressed with the amount of work that went into finding out and
understanding that experience.
And actually you were just talking about this,
that the story beautifully contrasts two different journeys,
right?
Of immigrants that have different experiences.
Um,
our nation often tends to privilege certain minorities over others.
And what I like this,
that you,
you are treading lightly.
Like you want it to dig deep and information about the Latin x experience,
but you want it to make sure that you did it well.
So I personally think that you took the time and you handled it very eloquently
and beautifully,
and you are as a Latino,
I think you,
you told the story very well,
but did you ever feel,
uh,
maybe you were,
um,
and,
and I asked this a kind of contentious question,
um,
in terms of cultural appropriation,
like what is the fine line between being an ally and telling,
uh,
someone else's experience from your perspective to show your allyship,
um,
versus,
you know,
potentially appropriate in that culture?
Yeah,
that's a good question.
I did struggle with this idea of appropriation and whether I was telling
someone's story when I shouldn't be telling their story.
So the way I approached that was first of all,
to accept the fact that I would never truly understand solely,
you know,
my Mexican character.
Like I can never truly understand the Latin x experience.
I can never truly understand the undocumented experience.
Um,
so one thing that I eventually realized that I had to do was after all the
research,
which was necessary,
I had to figure out how I personally related to solely to my character.
And,
um,
I eventually realized that,
you know,
this was essentially a story about a young woman who became a mother and he
wanted certain things for herself and the fact that she was let Latina,
the fact that she was undocumented,
these all determine the trajectory of her story,
but they were not the story itself.
Um,
so I was able,
I tried to connect with her in that way and um,
you know,
I just had to realize I had to accept that I was never going to do it complete
justice and I just had to tread carefully and make her as fully fledged as I
could.
Was a former Spanish teacher.
Your pronunciation of all the names is absolutely
made me very happy.
Great.
So obviously the topic of lucky boy is very timely,
not only internally here at Google,
but domestically and globally,
particularly in the last few months.
What a struggles or obstacles do you feel you faced as an author writing about
this topic
in 2017 struggles as an author?
Um,
you know,
there is,
there was this looming question of cultural appropriation.
You know,
that's a big issue for us right now.
Um,
I did sort of wonder initially if this book was going to be sort of taken up,
you know,
I'm not,
it's not your classic American novel about people in Upper East side Manhattan.
Um,
in fact the,
you know,
the people who are white,
they're sort of on the periphery of this book.
And so I did wonder,
you know,
if that,
if the fact that I had,
you know,
this group of Brown people and Brown woman and everyone is brown,
if that would be sort of a,
an obstacle to getting it published.
And at one point I said to my agent,
you know,
it wasn't getting published.
I went through like two or three rounds of projections and I said to my agent,
maybe I should just make all my Indians white and see what happens.
And she was like,
absolutely not.
He's like,
no.
Well,
she pointed out to me that this is not just about a Mexican woman.
This is a story of immigrants on American soil in 2000 whatever it was.
Then 2000,
you know,
the two thousands and so that allowed me to sort of take a new perspective on
what I was doing.
So,
yeah.
Um,
so in looking into your,
your future endeavors,
what's next?
It could be a specific book or do you think you found a,
your area and you want to continue talking about uh,
the immigrant experience?
I kind of want to do both,
so I'm going to start slowly working on it on my next book as soon as all this
touring and,
and I also feel like,
you know,
I've written this book so this is what I'm grappling with.
You know,
I've written this book,
it's,
it's about this topic.
What am I just going to drop it now and like talk about something else next.
You know,
cause I feel like now that I've written this book,
I want to do something more with it.
I want to actually use it in some way to enact some beginnings of change and
something that I care about.
So hopefully I'll do that.
Yeah.
And just out of curiosity,
obviously you're a writer,
were all super excited that this book is out.
Um,
nothing but positive feedback at least that I've seen.
but,
uh,
what are some of your favorite authors?
What do you like to read?
Do you look up to,
who inspires you?
My favorite authors.
So for this book in particular,
I really looked to beloved by Toni Morrison,
um,
because for one thing,
on a technical level,
I was trying to figure out how to work with past and present.
And in beloved,
Tony Morrison does this beautiful job with memory where she passes seamlessly
from the present day narrative into her characters,
um,
days as a slave and her journey up north as a slave.
And when I was writing this,
I literally had my little notebook.
It was like on the 20th revision or whatever.
I had my little notebook and I would copy out Tony Morrison's sentences just to
sort of understand like how she made those transitions.
So beloved by Toni Morrison,
I really liked Zadie Smith.
She's a British writer and,
and the end,
right.
Um,
her book,
the green road kind of influenced this.
I like reading writers whose,
whose voices are very different from my own.
It loosens up something in me creatively.
Wonderful.
We definitely want to give the audience an opportunity to ask questions.
Um,
I haven't read your book yet,
but I look forward to it.
But I hear you telling the stories of two Brown women who have had the
experience of like being immigrants or second generation immigrants in America.
And then I hear about your op Ed,
which talks about like the privileged immigrant and then obviously the flip side
of that is the like unprivileged or underprivileged immigrant.
Okay.
Sorry.
Um,
so I was just wondering like what you think,
why you think those two narratives that sounds so similar at their root have
developed so differently in America and what we can learn from deconstructing
those.
So the two narratives,
they have evolved very differently on American soil.
Um,
to some extent,
you know,
it's not a matter of what country you come from.
It's a matter of the,
uh,
the,
the structure is that you've been able to put in place for yourself.
So if we talk about my characters,
you know,
caveat and Rishi,
they own this little house in Berkeley.
They were able to buy that house because their parents were able to help them
buy that house.
And I never really go into what their parents did for a living.
But,
um,
the assumption is that their parents,
you know,
were similar to my parents.
They came over in the 60s,
seventies had good,
stable jobs,
are able to accrue some savings and then,
um,
if you have someone like solely,
you know,
she sort of kept her money in her home,
she wasn't able to invest.
And so much of this,
so much of this just comes down to the technicalities of money and land and you
know,
neighborhoods,
the neighborhoods and the schools that you're able to send your children to.
And,
and I guess the choice,
I guess really what it comes down to is,
is the power to choose where you want to live and what you want to do with your
life and for your children.
And I think that that really has informed the various trajectories that we see
in the u s
just very quickly,
particularly on that point in the op Ed in the New York Times you mentioned that
it's not one Imon Group,
immigrant group is better or stronger and more competent than the other,
but rather the opportunities or the path that has already created for them in
this nation before they come here.
Right.
So I think that distinction that you made was beautiful.
Thank you.
Um,
so you live in Berkeley and you've written a book about,
um,
the topic good in some parts of the country,
kind of like plays better,
better accepted than they were in other parts of the country.
I'm curious,
uh,
if you're going to other parts of the country and if in those places,
like,
is this more or less of like a political novel?
Is there some sort of statement about that based on where you are,
who you're even talking with?
Yeah.
Talking to about it.
So whether or not this is a political novel,
that usually comes down to the individual reader.
So people who really want to engage with the political aspects of this,
they'll talk to me about that.
And people,
some people are just not very politically engaged and so they see it for like
the,
the interpersonal drama of the book and in terms of traveling to different parts
of the country.
So I've been mostly on the west coast and then like New York and DC.
But I did go down to Dallas and I've been waiting,
you know,
for the person with the red hat to stand up and ask me some questions what they
haven't yet.
I find,
you know,
if,
if I assume that there is dissent,
I assume that there are going to be people around who don't like what I'm
talking about in this book.
But they haven't said anything yet.
And I think that like a lot of us,
when they don't like something,
they,
they're keeping quiet or they're just not thinking about it.
So that's,
how would I respond to that?
Dissent.
I'd first want to know if they read the book.
You know,
cause I feel like if you,
when you engage with someone's story and you really sort of connect to them as a
character,
like you,
you start to see things in a more complex way than you would normally.
Um,
and I guess I would,
I would want to listen to where they're coming from.
You know,
it's,
I'm not the sort of writer who can get into a political argument with the
reader.
Um,
but I could talk to them about the issues within the book.
And really,
you know,
I can't,
I can't pretend to want to convert people,
but I want people to understand that this is a more complex situation than they
may have initially assumed.
I'm curious,
you mentioned that you're a teacher and you're a mother and you wrote this book,
obviously.
I'm just curious how you structure your time and like what a day in the life is
like when you're working on a book like this that requires so much research and
time and engagement.
Yeah,
so I,
it was very slow.
Um,
I should say I wrote most of it when I had just one kid not to because when you
have to,
it's like you have a thousand.
Um,
so basically what I would do is I would drop my kid off at preschool.
I was teaching at the same time but only part time at a,
at an art college at CCA.
And so I would drop my kid off at preschool,
take Bart into San Francisco.
I used to go to the writer's grotto in San Francisco to write a lot.
Um,
so I'd have one or two days where I would just spend the day there and then be
back in Berkeley for like the 4:00 PM pickup at preschool.
And so I had a couple of days like this per week that were just completely
devoted to the book and slowly,
slowly,
you know,
it builds and at a certain point you get enough into the book that you can just
write anywhere at anytime,
you know,
you can be standing on a bus and writing.
Yeah.
How long did the whole thing take?
So it took about two and a half years for one,
and then it was about three and a half more years of reworking it and editing.
Yeah.
That was a lot slower than I thought.
I thought I'd like write it and it would be ready,
but no.
Yeah,
I haven't read the book that,
I'm curious,
how do you set on it,
on the title when there's these paths of luck and unluck depending on the
different journeys and where their characters are in there and their stages of
their lives.
Yeah,
so the title,
you know,
I never thought of lucky is in terms of the character's journeys,
but I guess it does apply to that.
So lucky boy refers primarily to Ignacio who's a little boy born to solely.
And it's,
um,
it has sort of a,
an ironic side,
but also a sincere side.
He's sincerely lucky because he has these two mothers who love him and want him
and he's not so lucky because it's this love that sort of pulls apart his
destiny.
He doesn't know where he's gonna land or we don't know where he's going to land
really.
Um,
and in terms of picking the title,
I think this was maybe the fifth or sixth title than I settled on.
Can we ask what some of the other titles where,
Oh yeah.
So I think,
um,
the first one where I didn't really know where this was going completely was our
winning smiles,
which is from the Belle and Sebastian song.
I just,
I liked it.
Um,
and then there was some not so great ones,
but one of the other major ones was season of the beast because I,
um,
that that image of the beast comes up a lot.
But also there's lobbyists,
Thea,
which is the freight train that migrants right up through Mexico.
Um,
they write the top of it and it's,
it's pretty dangerous that's in here as well.
And um,
at one point in this is bad.
So at one point as Ignacio's nickname that his mother gives him is not shown.
So at one point it was not show,
exclamation mark.
Um,
and then eventually there's this one line that Tom has the phrase lucky boy in
the book.
And so eventually I was like,
oh,
okay,
I'll just go with that.
And my editor wanted to change it and then we decided not to.
Um,
so thank you so much for coming.
We had a blast.
Really appreciate it.
Thanks.
[inaudible].